welcome to the Daily I'm Neil Patterson
and today while we're focusing on the
worsening situation in Sudan over the
weekend British diplomatic staff and
their families were evacuated from the
region yet Perhaps as many as 4 000
British passport holders remain in the
country and the foreign secretary has
said the government's ability to help is
severely limited until the conflict ends
yet there is precious little chance of
that happening as the violence escalates
between the Sudanese Army and the
paramilitary group the rapid Supply
forces or rsf who actually fought
alongside Sudanese forces in the coups
of 2019 and 2021. so far the advice to
Brits has been to stay out of sight
indoors but other countries including
France and Germany have managed to get
both their diplomats and other Nationals
out of Sudan short of a long dangerous
Journey to the Egyptian border there is
little the four thousand British
Nationals can do but sit wait and
presumably pray
I'm going to be speaking about the lack
of an active evacuation plan with our
defense and security editor and to one
woman whose family including her
daughters aged just five and two are
desperate to flee the country yes they
were terrified because the house just
behind them
uh was hit by a bomb but they can hear
the gunfires and they can hear the bombs
through inside the house but first our
Africa correspondent yusra El bhagya is
in Djibouti a country several hundred
miles outside of Sudan but where planes
transporting foreign Nationals out of
the capital Khartoum continue to land
like you sir are any British passport
holders outside of the Diplomatic staff
are they getting out of the country at
the moment I mean one of those that
remain actually telling you they're
trapped they feel trapped we spoke to a
head teacher of a of a school uh who was
incredibly frustrated he said that him
and his fellow Brits were you know using
every swear word Under the Sun to
express their frustration uh he's from
Coventry and him and his wife went out
there to teach we've spoken to Jewel
Nationals who uh feel who've literally
you know come to Sudan just to see their
family uh one NHS clinical psychologist
went to Sudan for for a funeral and is
now trapped there and she says that a
hundred NHS doctors are currently
trapped in Sudan at the moment and
they're not receiving help from the
embassy but they've also been it's been
very clearly indicated that dual
National Sudanese Brits will be at the
bottom of the pile when civilians
British citizens are finally evacuated
how do we know this and in what way has
this been indicated that they will be
the last to be rescued some have said
that they've received that from the
embassy and I would just say Neil we're
waiting to get evidence on what exactly
was said to them but the testimonies
that people are sharing online is that
the embassies basically told them don't
hold your breath
um and that they should just you know
that they won't be when it does finally
happen they shouldn't expect that
they'll be evacuated
so so it's certainly the case that it is
not just Britain that it's that is
having issues getting people out of the
country by the same token however I mean
isn't it the case that other countries
have managed to extract their civilians
along with their diplomatic staff at the
same time
definitely I mean the French have
managed to evacuate large numbers of
foreign Nationals that include dual
citizens there are other Nationals from
across Africa as well as across the EU
that have been evacuated by the French
the Italians are also evacuating
non-italian foreign Nationals there's
been kind of a more integrated approach
I would say from Italy and France than
what we've seen from the UK and I think
it's important to mention that the U.S
also focused on their diplomatic staff
and only evacuated their Embassy
personnel and their dependence you so
that you you mentioned that there has
been not a complete cessation of
violence in Sudan but but the temple
appears to have dropped know that
significant numbers of foreign Nationals
have left the country not Brits of
course but significant numbers of other
foreign Nationals are we to expect the
violence to tick back up again
that's what's expected that's that year
is that this sort of Illusion operation
will seize as soon as they are not no
longer feeling responsible or that they
will be held accountable and I think
this speaks to the impunity that we've
seen over the last few years and the
enablement by the International
Community in mediation efforts so the
feeling now is that they've just been
left by the wayside both dual Nationals
and Sudanese civilians are making the
perilous Journey to the border to Egypt
to the eastern border to Ethiopia and
trying to get themselves out
you mentioned on on a podcast around
about a week ago yusra um that you have
family that were there and they were
caught up in all of this I'm wondering
how they're doing
my parents are still there um and
they're elderly and they do not feel
comfortable to make the journey it's not
an easy Journey it's taken P it takes
people
you know a full day of travel to Egypt
and there's a lot of reports of
abductions looting killing on the road
my parents don't feel comfortable we've
tried to persuade them but unfortunately
it's a choice that people have to make
these are people who are leaving
everything we don't have a welfare
system in Sudan that provides social
housing so the houses that we see that
are destroyed and looted are people's
generational homes that they've built
Brick by Brick and so to leave is an
impossible decision and to stay is an
impossible decision and that's what
people are currently facing
tell me just a little bit more about
that exit route the the dangers that
people are feeling reports of people
getting abducted getting killed I mean I
can understand why your parents wouldn't
want to leave their home
yeah it's terrifying especially if
you're not able-bodied you are unwell if
you're elderly and if you're super young
there's been a lot of advice for people
to travel in big groups there's been a
massive Community initiative people all
over the Sudanese Community all over the
world working lines we had someone
helping us get family out who we don't
even know I just got sent her number and
we called her and her name is Mesa she's
in Saudi Arabia and she's just been
bashing phone lines trying to find a
secure route for some of our neighbors
and the people that we know everyone's
banding together because this is just so
dangerous people are being you know if a
car looks nice they'll just take it if
people look vulnerable or they have
money or they have any sort of
indication of even just political
affiliation if you've been an activist
over the last few years then you've got
a Target on your back so the the roots
are just almost impossible to travel but
people have no choice indeed just to
return to the kind of the 4 000 or so
British passport holders that we think
are still in Sudan you know the foreign
secretary has been very very clear I
mean he has said that the UK is is
severely limited in its ability to help
British Nationals until the conflict
ends I mean from your perspective do you
think that there is any chance that we
will see massive accusations of British
passport holders given the level of
violence and given what the foreign
secretary has just said it doesn't look
great Neil I have to say it looks like
if you're an EU citizen if you're from
you know Ireland if you're from France
if you're from Italy you have a better
chance of being evacuated than if you're
a Brit and people are incredibly sad
about that and Sudan you have to
remember Sudan is a former British
colony there's a reason that there are
so many Brits in Sudan there there's a
reason why there are so many Sudanese
Brits and so many Sudanese people in the
UK
there is a there is a responsibility
here that is historical
um and there should be safe Passage
through back and forth from the UK just
given the history and given the fact
that
Sudan sees itself in many ways as as a
as a former colony and suffers from the
repercussions of being a former Colony
even in its lack of State Building and
its lack of Economic Development today
with the country beginning to experience
shortages of vital medicine food and
water many will surely be considering
attempting to flee but a series of
ceasefires have failed to hold the
violence continues and the road out is
dangerous indeed
is in London but her family has been
trapped into Sudan it was terrifying for
my oldest daughter she's five years old
the first day she couldn't sleep out of
Terry Terror my mother had to tell her
that these people are just doing some
training
literary training but we are safe and
nothing will happen to us
sadly she had to lie because my daughter
was terrified
from what she was hearing
my youngest was two years old
was again terrified every time she hears
the sound
my five-year-old is
um
she hears us talking about anything she
would get terrified so
she had to go somewhere where they
couldn't hear us to tell me about it
for two days they had no electricity at
all
um
these were really stressful times
talking to them
chassis family have French nationality
so is the conflict worsened her mother
brother and two young daughters fled the
family home with their belongings to
make a dangerous Journey to the French
Embassy in the hope of getting out
that's where the hard part is
um moving from where they were to the
French Embassy it's quite dangerous they
had to go through streets and there's
open fire although there should be some
ceasefire at the moment to get the four
Nationals out
I've lost contact them contact with them
since the moment they've left a lot
until they've reached the French Embassy
hours and hours later they did make it
to the Embassy after hours of agonizing
pain for shaza but the pen continues as
she waits for further information about
their safety the last she heard they
were due to be on a flight but when we
spoke to her she hadn't had any
information for more than 12 hours how
are you feeling right now we are in a we
are in a horrible horrible moment I
suspect for you assuming that they are
on their way to safety but but not
having that that confirmed I I just I'm
just wondering how your coping shadow
was working and taking my thoughts of
what's happening to my family into that
last night I've heard about I would say
three hours of sleep
um
just because I've been up for more than
30 hours in a row and I couldn't get any
sleep prior to this
and literally after three hours I was
just awake looking at my phone making
phone calls trying to see if they've
contacted anyone I still don't have any
information where they are or
whether they've actually made it to
safety or not
and we will of course update you as to
shaza's situation the Sudanese Army and
the paramilitary rapid Supply forces
fought side by side in the coups of 2019
and 2021 but the relationship has since
sowed and there are long-standing
disagreements over how the country
should be run which has led to the
violence I spoke to our defense and
security editor Deborah Haynes just
before lunchtime on Monday the 24th of
April since then a team of British
troops have flown into a port in eastern
Sudan some distance from the capital on
what we're told is a reconnaissance
mission there's always a plan there are
lots of plans the problem is that
so the
the escalating violence and the
deteriorating safety situation in the
cartoon for a number of of weeks not
just days they would have been looking
at all sorts of different options to get
British Nationals out it's an incredibly
difficult situation and the location is
hard because
um we don't have bases around the the
region as countries like France and the
US do they've both got bases in Djibouti
which is a few hundred miles from Sudan
but that's a lot better than anything
that we've got and so the logistics is
incredibly hard Sudan is a very big
country and also there's a war group
there's conflict going on so there are
loads of checkpoints there are armed
um soldiers from both sides it's very
very dangerous but yes lots of plans but
no decisions so I presume that for the
time being at least the advice is what
just to stay indoors and which for wait
for a call from the FCO I mean clearly
that that advice cannot hold the only
choice they've got is it has been to
stay at home but clearly doing that
isn't a plan because water's running out
electricity is pretty much non-existent
um they're going to have to get out
somehow they can't just keep staying
there and so that's what you're seeing
these these unilateral Decisions by
people to get on other means of of
Transport out
um but I imagine before the pressure is
really mounting on the foreign office
today to do more to be to give a better
plan to get people out and then there
are also questions about
um about taking all the diplomats out
and leaving British Nationals in of
course other countries are doing the
same so clearly there's um there's a
wider consideration here about what is
genuinely practical and safe and the
decision was clearly taken that the
diplomats in the embassy that were there
couldn't perform their function because
of the security situation is there a is
there a solid piece of evidence that
suggests that the militiamen were going
to be targeting foreign diplomats
working in the country because otherwise
if I were a British passport holder
watching the ambassador of the
Diplomatic staff get evacuated from the
country but I'm still there I might be
slightly less sympathetic than you just
were in it is the case that the embassy
and the location of the embassy and
where the Diplomatic staff were living
is is literally in the middle of the the
two warring factions so it's true that
it that they were in a difficult
position and I think if they're they're
not they're clearly it's not an embassy
that's
um that's got that's a sort of a sort of
a military base so they can't defend
themselves uh and so there was
definitely the risk I mean the in all of
the uh briefings about this from the
government they specifically said that
there's been evidence of a escalating
threat or a threat against diplomatic
missions uh we know for example that the
British Council building
um there was reports of it being looted
after the uh the officials from the
council uh moved home they left that
building
um and so I think there was there is
some legitimacy there but clearly the
whole the whole city is is a dangerous
place to be and so it's going to be slim
comfort
what if anything then is your best guess
as to how we will get British Nationals
out of the country given all the
problems that you've mentioned well well
I think if a decision is taken that we
have to get the British Nationals out
and keeping that policy of stay in
shelter is no longer viable then clearly
it's going to be an operation that the
British will be doing alongside
International allies and so you can
imagine for the ministry of Defense
they'll be looking at the possibility
again maybe of trying to get um to get
an aircraft into the Airfield that they
used at the weekend which is just North
of Khartoum again trying to get people
out of the city that is very high risk
it's what they did to get the diplomats
out but if they wanted to do that again
to get British Nationals out that's a
high risk move but it can be done
they've proven that it can be done and
the other alternative is to try to get
people to one of Sudan's borders maybe
the on the coast have a ship there get a
royal Navy warship and anything that
they do they'll be doing it in
coordination with European countries
France Germany for example as well and
also the United States and others
because they're all in this dilemma
together and clearly other countries
have decided to get their their
Nationals out not just their diplomats
that's not a good look for the UK all of
which takes us surely straight back to
Afghanistan again I mean the the head of
the Foreign Affairs select committee has
been seeing this morning look people
have not been communicated with
appropriately we haven't got a plan in
place we have not learned the lessons
from Afghanistan I mean how true is that
from your perspective I mean it's true
here we are again with a crisis
situation with the foreign office uh
saving you doing all it it can but it
has only limited resources I really
think this is a reflection of the
erosion in funding and capability at the
heart of the UK's
um key Ministries in particular the
foreign office it's been reduced over
time in terms of size and influence and
as well as that of course the Armed
Forces they've been massively shrunk too
and it means that your options just
shrink along with that and there just
hasn't
enough foresight in place to think about
this potentially coming and then even
when it blew up literally a week and a
half ago it seems that it was the
military that had the plans but the
foreign office that was quite slow and
you're left in this situation where yet
again British Nationals
um are stuck in a conflict Zone with
with no way out in Afghanistan the
difference there was that there was a a
relatively permissive environment the
Taliban as you'll remember had given the
uh the British and the US and the others
just under three weeks to get their
people out they had an Airfield to do
that in Sudan they do not have these
um these permissions you had to you have
to work very very hard in order to get
permission to land aircraft in an
Airfield that's not guaranteed to be
defended uh there's reports that one of
the French convoys came under Fire
yesterday it is high risk it's not a
permissive environment there isn't a
British military footprint on the ground
so it's just very very different so you
can't compare exactly but you can say
that yet again it doesn't seem that
there was a lot of pre-planning going on
for this potential eventuality which has
now just blown up in everybody's faces
foreign
and of course to you for listening to
the Sky News Daily with me Neil
Patterson this Edition was produced by
Emery Woodhouse and Alex Eden our editor
is Philly Bowman
foreign